this video is brought to you by raycon
and then
gone and the weird cat creature lived
happily ever
after the end wow it's crazy how much
can change in a single week huh
i mean i normally cover about 30
chapters of the story for these videos
and then give you my take on it the only
problem is that with these latest 30
chapters
i was bored out of my mind by them now
that's not to say it was super bad or
anything just that
i wasn't exactly impressed or even had
that much fun reading it the material is
very much setting up the chess pieces
for the next 30 chapters after and so
guess what i did yeah you guessed it
this week i'm reviewing 60 chapters of
hunter hunter's chimera ants arc because
if i just did 30 all you would hear is
about 15 minutes of complaining and
if living with my parents has taught me
anything it's that complaining gets you
the wooden spoon now there will be some
complaining in this review and by some i
mean
quite a lot lord knows i deserve it
after constantly praising the story but
i will also be praising it highly in the
second half and where i think it's
necessary so
strap in and strap on because we are
about to go deep into this dense thick
series
i'm totally not mark i'm not okay and
this is my ra i mean review
of the chimera ants arc part 2.
[Music]
so yeah as i said this week i'm covering
60 chapters instead of the usual 30 and
let me tell you
stuff happens but also stuff doesn't
happen
a lot following gone getting his nan
back after his fight with knuckle
there's a lot of attention given to this
one specific scene
and what a scene morel one of the lead
hunters spearheading the assault on the
chimera ants alongside the tarot asks
for gun to prove himself by punching him
which ends up being a
big mistake since the very beginning of
this series there's been a concerted
effort to exhibit for us
gon's psychological state and how it
determines the fate of himself
his enemies and even extreme points like
this his friends
something that was mentioned maybe as
far back as the heavens arena arc was
that nen is closely linked to your
emotional or
psychological state i remembered that
small passing piece of exposition
because
i knew it would eventually translate to
if someone gets big mad then they get
big strong
and with a character like gone a small
child searching for a father that we've
all come to know as emotionally
unavailable or
sort of weird at the very least there's
been at least for me a touch of dramatic
irony because
as a reader i'm aware of something gone
isn't i'm aware that there will come a
time where he will be shocked or
disillusioned by
jing and as a result this small piece of
passing exposition concerning men will
come into play
and shockingly it did so much sooner
than i thought it would faced with the
possible death of kite someone he deeply
cares for
faced with what has already been done to
him and wanting to get revenge
on those that did it to him gone when
asked to prove his strength by punching
an established and powerful hunter
proves in that moment that the emotional
turmoil that resides beneath the surface
of his cheerful disposition can fuel an
attack more powerful than anything we
thought he was capable of refraining
from attacking at the last possible
moment thanks to kilauea
gone could have in that moment killed
morel now that's terrifying and i think
that while the main villain isn't all
that compelling yet i mean he does get a
little bit more compelling later
i genuinely believe that at this moment
in time he exists to act as a stressor
for gun and somehow i feel
given the real meat of this material the
main portion of this conflict won't be
found with the king but perhaps
instead the inner conflict between two
individuals gon
and kilauea and while we're on the topic
of kilauea i think i should address
something that i wanted to speak on
last week while killable removed the
antenna from his head i personally
wasn't 100 sure
what would come from this but now having
read ahead i can confirm for myself that
it is exactly what he said it was an
antenna manipulating him
alright so time for my thoughts from a
fan standpoint i
really like that kilauea is in control
again but from a critical one
i'm a little uncertain on one hand it
was great to see him physically overcome
a hole his family has over him this as
you know
plays into the themes of oppression and
familial obligation kilauea has been
fighting against in the story since he
joined it way back during the hunter
exams however
and this is a big however the implant in
his mind while
not breaking any rules of the world i
think in a way
it felt a little anticlimactic replacing
what appeared to be
a compelling and genuine case of
psychological trauma with a
tangible antenna making for a quick
solution to what was initially implied
to be a much
much more complicated problem and so
after discovering and confirming that it
was all just an actual antenna
controlling a part of his actions it
felt as though a tremendous amount of
potential was lost for a compelling and
intense story which hunter hunter seems
to be exploring more readily with gun
throughout the beginning of
this story kilowatt was trying to become
a hunter seemingly this was his first
venture and decision made for himself
and
no one else however despite his internal
desire to do something for himself
it was his family's domineering presence
that consistently prevented killuba from
achieving such
the whole no matter how hard he tried he
would still be the person his family
trained him to be
that reality and that theme was intense
in this story and it was compelling
because we thought it was something
deeply ingrained
in kilauea from a metaphorical
standpoint and not a literal one
this mind control device in my opinion
sort of cheapens and fundamentally
changes that entire dynamic it wasn't
that he might actually be like his
family or that he can shake his
upbringing or genetics or whatever
instead it was
a piece of metal in his head and now
that it's removed he has full control
over his destiny it seems whether i take
this as a metaphor or at face value it
is vastly less interesting to me
than what i and i assume everyone else
thought was going on the reason why
kilauea is relatable in some instances
is because he embodies that one kid that
while having massive potential to do one
thing
is held back by the bad teachings of his
family to do another something like that
can't be overcome
just like that but by truly fighting
tooth and nail
against those bad teachings over many
many years
now thankfully this moment kilowatt
decides to flick that switch for himself
does come about during an intensely
emotional moment
wanting to protect his friend which is
exactly what it needed to be
but again the means with which this
comes about seems
deeply unsatisfying to me but yeah
that's killerwood that's gone and that's
the stuff that happens in the first few
chapters so
what's next well there's some cool
introspective board game sequences with
the king of the chimera ants and this
little girl called komugi
it's a really interesting way of coming
to understand the character before he
really starts to understand himself
asking himself questions like who are
you why are you here
what's your purpose throughout this
section the chimera and king was giving
me
major mewtwo strikes back vibes and i
can't be the only person who thought
that either at every crossroads he faces
when left to his own devices
self indulges in a much more negative
path or mindset however when
all the cards or tiles are down with
this little girl
he respects he shows a very different
side to himself
outside of the beginning this is the
best stuff i thought that was covered in
the story from a narrative perspective
there's a clear parallel being
established here with gon
and this chimera ant king and i really
can't wait to see how this develops
further it was
really interesting to me but the rest
was
that's right now i gotta talk about my
first major issue with this week's
material
chapters 220 to 263 are almost
entirely waiting heck even the chapter
titles are in on the joke here
literally counting down from ten to one
initially i thought this was funny but
then i realized that this portion of the
story actually achieves
very very little now
i'm sure most people wouldn't be
bothered by this nearly as much as i was
but
god damn i was really bored i'd even go
as far as to say that the material after
gone's almost murder and before the
palace attack
might be the weakest in the series in
terms of actual story progression and my
overall
interest on paper the concept seems fine
build tension slowly to this massive
genocide planned by the ants
all the while the sight of good makes
preparations to stop this all from
happening
and normally this would be a good idea
you need a can before the storm in
stories like this but this
cam spans across three entire volumes of
the story
and in those volumes the story felt like
it had more padding than the 1990s
version of the dragon ball z
anime and this is a manga and as a
result
dragged the plot to a screeching halt
sometimes even cutting away to
characters that have
quite literally nothing to do with this
story for like
five or six chapters at a time for the
purposes of this video i had to read
six or so volumes of manga and let me
tell you
this volume volume 22 delivered me an
experience i don't think any manga i've
ever read has given
me and not a good one i found the
material in this volume
so insanely boring i actually had to
step away for an entire day
just to work up to reading more of it
now before anyone goes off in the
comment section saying that they loved
it and that it's great for x y and z
reason that's totally fine that's your
experience that's
real it's valuable and i can't take that
away from you but
mine is real too and my god i
hated this volume nothing happens to say
that this volume absolutely and
unequivocally annihilated the pacing of
the story for me would be an
understatement
of a lifetime at this moment in time the
chimera ants arcs plot
focuses on and draws our interest to
characters like
kite gone kilauea maybe smaller
secondary characters trying to get us to
know them but predominantly those
characters as they deal with the
aftermath and plan to exterminate the
king chimera
however in this volume a considerable
amount of it 60
is spent with the phantom troop and
shows us what other parts of the world
are like
now that the chimera ants have
infiltrated their regions now
you might be thinking hmm i wonder what
role the phantom troop will play in this
arc
how will they affect the developing
personalities and struggles of the main
cast
well they don't it was here i was forced
to realize the phantom troops greatest
weakness also
for me at least there's sort of an
ensemble characters like uvo in york new
city was given the most characterization
during that portion and
he died additionally the character of
paku received a similar amount of
endearment to me as a reader for the
exposure and stresses she was put under
during that material too
unfortunately both of these characters
met untimely
ends during that material leaving only
one other character that received any
meaningful exposure to us
as an audience and that was nobunaga and
he wasn't present
in this material for the chimera and arc
at all because of this
i found myself spending the bulk of an
entire volume
following characters i was lukewarm on
facing off against enemies that are very
much secondary
while also not furthering the story in
any meaningful way
the scene exists to expose us to more of
the troop
and it succeeds in that effort sure but
outside of maybe showing us what other
places are like dealing with the ants
this portion of the material does little
else at this moment
in time which made it difficult to sit
through for me if i'm being perfectly
honest
the pacing really was destroyed for me
here now if i want to be completely fair
here it's entirely possible that their
presence may come into play later on in
the story beyond what i've read today
and lord knows i hope all that time i
spend reading it was worth something but
even if they do the means with which
they are integrated is about as subtle
as chronic dysentery
anyway to cut a long story short kilauea
meets character development and gun
meets plot device
they all meet up and all seem to be in
place for some story progression finally
now as we move on to the past assault
tagashi decides to implement some
significant changes
changes that i think are best
exemplified through this quote from the
manga
[Music]
something totally not mark thought was
quite strange was the sudden
participation of a disembodied narrator
from mark's experience with the manga he
didn't recognize this as a regular
occurrence
and yet by the time things started to
really kick off in chapter 263
the narration has already been going on
for roughly four chapters
mark decided to do some investigating
and went to check out how this was
handled in the anime
and found essentially the exact same
thing happening without this president
having been set
earlier seeing it suddenly come out of
nowhere in the manga
felt like a strange choice to mark and
he would argue that perhaps
even more so in the anime mark feels
that this isn't the anime's fault at all
they are adapting the manga is what you
might hear him say if he actually had
any dialogue during this part of the
video
mark feels as though people could argue
that this helps to make these events
feel even more special
and he understands that argument but for
him this only served to sort of
take him out of the story it made him
feel as though he
mark was reading about someone reading a
story to him little bits of this here
and there wouldn't bother him
but for multiple chapters back to back
mark just thinks it's a very odd
decision
and at times acts as a bit of a crutch
now
mark is open to being corrected on this
point if you feel he's wrong
but he believes this is an almost meme
level example of telling
and not showing an especially egregious
offense in a medium that makes showing
extremely simple this reads as if it was
a book
devoid of pictures the reason this makes
mark a little more annoyed than perhaps
it should
is that usually things like this telling
instead of showing
is the result of a lack of narrative
preparation
stories with no build up typically
suffer from this
an example of this that mark would give
if not for the fact that his thoughts
are inexplicably being narrated right
now
is the last airbender movie katara's
narration in this film tells us that
saka and princess yue became fast
friends and fell in love it does this
bizarrely instead of showing us as the
series did through slow build
up narration here is being used as a
crotch
now this arc spent the best part of 40
chapters
building up to an event and now mark has
to sit through what he believes is
clunky expository narration
as this place is being infiltrated there
are things discussed during this time in
detail
like knuckles ability to read a person's
aura level and from this
mark thinks he knows why the ark is
written this way
a few chapters prior tagashi said he was
sorry for the long wait and expressed
concern that many people
may have forgotten things at this point
and so
right now it's mark's theory that
tagashi is providing this narration
not for people like mark who've recently
read all of the story in one go
but instead has structured it this way
to help keep people in the loop
as they read the weekly releases the
shonen jump after the long wait
in volume form this isn't a good thing
going up the stairs literally every
single meaningful aspect of every fight
and using a [ __ ] elevator are all
narrated to the reader
this is one of the single most efficient
assassinations of an arc
mark thinks he's ever witnessed made all
the more frustrating for mark
because he has endured over 30 chapters
of effectively tenuous build-up
all for it to mean basically very little
at all
as mark sees it these are characters
mark feels he's been forced to spend an
ungodly amount of time with over the
course of the arc and for no real reward
mark believes people could completely
skip the first half of act two in fact
without really losing anything of
substance it's explained to the reader
in no uncertain terms
according to mark there's no subtext as
mark sees it nor anything to infer
it is quite literally telling the reader
what is happening
again according to mark in his last
video
mark admired and praised the beginning
of this arc for its use of subtext and
dilemma
saying questions with no answers
produced the best stories
well this to use the layman's terms
yeets
all of that out the window as far as
mark is concerned by telling the reader
in no uncertain terms
what everyone is thinking and feeling
and why they are thinking and feeling it
it sucks all of the drama out of the
scene for mark of course
and now he feels as though he's being
told a story about this event
rather than actually experiencing it
with the characters he's developed a
fondness for
mark is immeasurably frustrated and he
is still not done
when thinking about what tom was talking
about when talking about what mark had
been talking about when talking about
hunter hunter in the end i just couldn't
understand what they were talking about
[Music]
at this point you've probably heard of
ray j's raycon brand considering people
like snoop dogg and mike tyson are
obsessed with it and that's not without
reason
nowadays people are shifting more and
more towards wireless earbuds as their
daily drivers but
one of the biggest barriers to entry has
always been
price and this is where raycon comes in
their wireless earbuds start at half the
price of its competitors but certainly
not
half the quality whichever of the many
colors or patterns you choose from
you're getting a great sound
product and i am loving the v-shaped
sound signature these things have
they really pack a punch in the low end
while keeping the clarity in the highs
and mids
it's a very premium sound all in a
compact
noise isolating fit seriously earbuds
come out of my ears
all the time normally but i can dance
around like a lunatic with these things
in my ears and they won't budge at all
they're absolutely perfect for my daily
routines like walking the dog or going
for a run and
most critically they're convenient the
bluetooth pairing is seamless and easy
meaning the moment i need them they're
ready to go
if these sound good to you and you want
to support the channel then click the
link in the description or go to
byraycon.com not mark to get 15
off your recon purchase and with a 45
day free return policy you can try them
yourselves and see if you agree with me
i'll be enjoying these this summer so i
hope you do too
i've had it
[Music]
additionally there are further changes
made not just to the story but
to the visuals one of the upshots to
reading a manga for me was the visceral
gore that accompanied the different
exchanges that took place without
compromise
many different anime adaptations opt to
censor the gore that would otherwise be
present in the manga and while this can
be at times fine
sometimes it can really take away from
the power of a scene
but now for whatever reason as i'm
reading
the great artwork gets obstructed by
this weird
sort of out of place black shading
texture box
it's a travesty now i can't see someone
holding a bunch of thumbs or
see someone's head get twisted off by
kilowatt i demand
my fist of thoughts furthermore
throughout these 60 chapters there were
some great moments that i enjoyed too
moments that made my life easier as i
waited through this
material that wasn't connecting with me
at all however
most of them unfortunately came with
some sort of caveat any time the cheat
who clashes with morel
is a pretty fun affair employing a great
strategy on behalf of the protag while
making full use of the nen power system
his first altercation alongside knuckle
is great but his real power is on full
display in his second fight with
chitu wherein we see his cunning and
patience used to full
effect in this arc battles are won not
just on feeling and strength alone but
through patience and measured approaches
something that gone isn't exactly on
board with right now but
i'll be sure to talk about that a little
later outside of that the character of
knuckle gets some tremendous treatment
in this material
while i didn't really care at all about
shoot knuckle was a personality that was
the clear highlight among all of the new
characters for me he's active
funny and personable endearing himself
to me almost
immediately in the earlier material
covered last week with further burst of
awesomeness this week
after the assault on the palace and this
palace is where things start to
really kick off chapter 263 to be
precise
something powerful is falling from the
sky that's caught pito's attention
and it's the tarot these subsequent
chapters are
total highlights and i'm certain given
the extent of what i can only describe
as
insufferable build up i'm sure once the
anime covered this material people must
have been extremely excited given that
natero is acting like a total boss and
we get a very punchy backstory
what i think is interesting concerning
this material though is that from the
moment he arrives to the moment
i reached 60 chapters in natero wasn't
shown attacking the king
at all in fact we don't see him attack
period for the entire time he's present
instead the focus is on the king chimera
who's acting completely different to
what they had anticipated with kilauea's
grandfather dipping due to how different
this situation was
with the king totally dedicated to the
protection and healing of the blind girl
he instructs pito
his strongest foot soldier to heal her
while he deals with natero
farther away to keep her safe and while
we don't see that fight
we do see something extremely
interesting instead of that as the hero
team
rushes to the compound
and just like that as if by magic out of
nowhere this scene catches my wavering
attention and gives it a much
needed kickstart and while i can say
that my enjoyment of it wasn't at least
a little bit affected by what came
before i most definitely did
thoroughly love this there are some
truly beautiful moments that made
exceptional use of the manga format in
chapter 275 the difference in the
composure and mental stability between
gon and kilauea is on full display for
all to see
it's stark and it's brilliant with guns
crumbling face on the top of one page
and once i turn to the next it's killer
was cam self there to reassure him
choices like these really help to
visually sell me on what's transpiring
in this material
watching as gone barely clings to his
sense of reason while killawa tries to
bring him back from the brink like he's
done
all so many times in the past was
possibly the most compelling instance
in this story and maybe not even just
this arc these drawings force you to
feel as gone does conflicted
angry devastated and struggling all of
these swirl in his head as he
desperately tries to find any excuse to
unload
all of this on pito but reality sinks in
pito is reasonable and shows how serious
they are
in this encounter forcing gun to explode
in frustration
though a frustration he's willing to
make peace with one hour
he will wait one hour and then peto has
to heal kite
if there's any takeaway i have for this
scene it's that it helped to restore
some hype in me for the conclusion of
this arc and elevate my hype levels for
another
awesome scene
this is all great action and after
watching this dude brutalize both shoot
and knuckle respectively which by the
way was way better than i anticipated it
being the combination of shoot
sacrifices
knuckles tenacious desperate strategies
all leading up to killua's last minute
save
made for one hell of a beatdown that
produced some of the most electrifying
kilowatt moments
overall and with us heading into the
final act which i assume will be awesome
or at least i hope it is i'm left
feeling
a little conflicted on one hand i can
absolutely
see and appreciate why so many people
love this arc
there's plenty of pivotal character arcs
either being stressed or paid off
it involves some of our favorite
characters from the past and it even
succeeds introducing us to plenty of new
endearing faces
all the while putting on some great
action however
i can't seem to get past the various
choices made and
pacing issues this arc suffers from in
my opinion
at no point during my read-through of
any of the other arcs in this collection
did i feel as bored as the middle of
this arc left me now i'm always on board
for a slow build up but
i thought this was a little excessive
while i'm sure the phantom troop have
a large fan base i couldn't help but
feel like their section was largely a
waste of time from a broader story
standpoint
i was happy that they were struggling or
agonizing over the perfect strat for
entering this hostile situation with the
chimera king
choices like that helped to build
credibility for the third act or climax
but at the end of the day i still
felt as though that they spent entirely
too much time setting it all up
considering
every story's plan eventually goes wrong
to create conflict so
in my mind i was waiting for this story
to get moving so that they could make a
plan
because i knew that this plan would
eventually fall through and they would
have to improvise
like they are doing right now and i
don't need to be a genius to figure that
one out i mean plans are made in stories
specifically to be broken so that
tension can rise
and what personally really annoyed me is
that i didn't even need to technically
understand the plan because when
everything is narrated from what the
characters do to what they think to what
their individual plans are
it doesn't require anyone in the
audience to understand their plan the
information during the narration is so
precise and on the nose that it
completely took me out of the experience
and removed the best part of reading a
manga for me
the subtext and so now that i've been
covering this story for a while and with
all of the arcs after settling in
somewhat for me
the strongest arc still might be the
hunter exams
it starts with a bang dotted throughout
our interesting pieces of
characterization there were magnificent
revelations throughout and most
importantly
there was a clear understanding as to
where we were going and there was
subtext
if your audience thinks it knows where
it's going as a writer that gives you a
lot of power to plan c's and switch
things up to this day i still think that
narratively one of the strongest moves
hunter hunter ever pulled off
was gunn vs hanzo the ninja before
quickly cutting to the end
that gave me the feels bonded me to the
character maintains snappy pasting and
it surprised me massively and the most
frustrating thing about
this arc the chimera ant arc is that
it's brilliant on paper
and yet its presentation totally sucked
me out of it
the best scene for me within this
material hands down that i cover today
has to be unseen with pito and kilauea
and why
because while the narration was still
there in parts most of it was dialogue
and thank god it was
or that scene could have been
compromised for me i don't need tagashi
to tell me how the character is feeling
on the inside
that's the subtext and this scene had so
much subtext you could read it all over
gone's face
and that's what i thought this arc
needed to do more of stop relying on the
narration i should be able to derive any
information i need from what they say to
each other
from their expressions or what they do
at the end of the day
this was a terrific story delivered in a
way that i just couldn't resonate with
and
may have left me a little disappointed
i'm delighted so many people across the
world disagree with me and love this arc
regardless with even some cases i'm sure
loving this because of the narration
with it amplifying the experience for
them i just
didn't share that experience i hope i
can enjoy the final section of this arc
lord knows things are heating up for
sure but until then
i've been totally not mark thank you so
much for watching and
i'll see you all next week
[Music]
yes